wir sind unterwegs nach almati
Kasachstan eine Insiderin will Auspacken
über Chinas Unterdrückungsapparat in der
uigurenprovinz
shinjang kaum jemand hat den Mut offen
zu reden auch unsere Zeugin will anonym
bleiben zunächst
jedenfalls es geht um jene berüchtigten
Teams die in Chinas Provinz shinjang
Menschen ausspionieren und in Lager
stecken während unseres Treffens
entscheidet sich GP quasibck um die
4jährige Kachin zeigt uns Ihren
arbeitsausweis will offen reden über das
Unrecht das China seinen Minderheiten
antut sie hat mitgemacht und darunter
gelitten sie fingen an die Leute in
größerer Zahl festzunehmen sie haben sie
selten am Tage festgenommen sondern eher
am
Abend hast du das selbst
gesehen ja hast du selbst
teilgenommen
ja
das Programm für das quasibck arbeitete
heißt fanguu eine lieblich klingende
Abkürzung die so viel bedeutet wie die
Menschen besuchen das Leben verbessern
die Gefühle des Volkes Vereinen in
Wahrheit ein System der
Unterdrückung wenn wir in ein Dorf
fahren müssen wir alles wissen was in
diesem Dorf geschieht wie viele Kinder
wurden geboren wer ist gestorben wer war
auf wessen Hochzeit das ist die
kernabsicht vanon Fang H
kann man das Überwachung nennen ja genau
Überwachung die Aussagen könnten zum
Problem werden für brsf und für ihn
Martin brudermüller den
Vorstandsvorsitzenden 2016 eröffnet
Bruder Müller ein Werk in China BSF
stellt dort in einem Joint Venture mit
einem chinesischen Partner ein
Vorprodukt für Sportbekleidung
her produziert wird in kla fast K
westlich von Peking mitten in der
Provinz
shinchang wie tief ist BSF verstrickt in
die Unterdrückung der
Uiguren sehr tief findet Adrian Zenz der
für ZDF frontal und den Spiegel
öffentlich zugängliche Berichte des BSF
Partners shinjang makco chemical
industry ausgewertet hat wenn man da mal
auf den ersten Report drauf klickt dann
hat mir hier sofort den diesen besonders
kompromittierenden Bericht in meinen
Jahren der Forschungsarbeit zu chinjang
habe ich das noch nie erlebt es geht um
Berichte wie diesen vom februar 2018
kurz vor dem chinesischen Neujahrsfest
machen marcor Mitarbeiter eine Art
Dienstreise ihr Ziel ist das Dorf
ang in dem Bericht heißt
es am Abend des 15 Februar Silvester gab
es für das erste fanghou Arbeitsteam von
maror ein einfaches
Abendessen da ist es wieder daswort für
Überwachung und
internierungen tatsächlich erreichen die
Massenverhaftungen genau zu diesem
Zeitpunkt im Frühjahr 2018 ihren
Höhepunkt haben Mitarbeiter eines BSF
Partners mit ihren Besuchen dazu
beigetragen anhand der von maror
selbstveröffentlichten Berichte ist es
offensichtlich dass makor
Mitarbeiter direkt an nicht nur der
staatlichen Sicherheit und der
Überwachung sondern auch an Aktivitäten
direkt teilgenommen haben die der
masseninternierung der Minderheiten
dienten die marcor Mitarbeiter machen
ganze Arbeit bei der
Überwachung es gibt 24 Haushalte die
gezielt kontrolliert werden müssen bei
der Sitzung wurden besondere
Vorkehrungen für nächtliche hausbesucher
getroffen gülpia quasibeck war für Staat
und Partei bei ähnlichen besuchen dabei
sie erinnert sich an einen Abend das
wieder Verhaftungen begannen
wir bekamen eine Liste von Häusern ihr
zwei geht dorthin ihr zwei geht dorthin
ihr zwei dorthin alle hatten Angst wenn
es heute dich trifft dann trifft es
morgen mich wir saßen im
Versammlungsraum und hatten alle Angst
so war es auch für die Dorfbewohner sie
sorgten sich jeden Tag darum wen sie als
nächstes verhaften sie fingen alle an
ihre Hosen zum Schlafen nicht
auszuziehen
von 40.000 Menschen seien am Ende 10 000
eingesperrt worden allein in ihrem
Gebiet BSF teilt mit bisher geb es keine
Anhaltspunkte dass Mitarbeitende der BSF
Joint Venture an Verhaftungen
teilgenommen hätten frühere
Überprüfungen hätten keine Hinweise auf
Zwangsarbeit oder
Menschenrechtsverletzungen ergeben
Zitat bislang hatten wir keine Kenntnis
von den genannten berichten von
201819 und den darin beschriebenen
Aktivitäten bei markor wir nehmen diese
Hinweise sehr ernst und werden Ihnen
weiter nachgehen erstaunlich die
Berichte sind öffentlich zugänglich also
meiner Meinung nach ist es unglaublich
dass BSF nach all diesen Jahren nach wie
vor diesen Standort in shinjang betreibt
und das einzig Richtige wäre natürlich
dass man zwar zu spät aber immerhin sich
jetzt noch sofort zurückzieht
aufgeschreckt durch unsere cherchen
setzt nun die Politik BASF massiv unter
Druck 30 Parlamentarier fordern von
Vorstandschef Bruder Müller BASF solle
sich aus shinjang
zurückziehen die Glaubwürdigkeit und
Integrität Ihres Unternehmens stehen auf
dem Spiel und wir glauben dass sie in
dieser Angelegenheit schnell und
entschlossen handeln müssen es muss für
unsere Unternehmen rote Linie geben und
Zwangsarbeit liegt hinter dieser roten
Linie und wenn jetzt der
Kooperationspartner von
BSF in China erwischt wird wie sie auf
der eigenen Website damit angeben dass
sie Teil dieses unterdrückungsregimes
sind dann muss die BSF da den Stecker
ziehen das ist eine für die BSF und auch
für Deutschland wirklich entsetzliche
Geschichte weil es sich um nicht weniger
handelt als um ein Unternehmen das in
der nszeit historisch belastet belastet
war und sich heute wieder indirekt
beteiligt an einem System das Tausende
von unschuldigen Menschen aus den
Häusern holt und in Massenlager treibt
BASF ist hervorgegangen aus dem
Chemiekonzern IG Farben der im
Nationalsozialismus Zwangsarbeiter
ausbeutete und das für den Massenmord in
den konzentrationslag genutzte Giftgas
Zyklon B
produzierte dre Stunden haben wir mit
göpia quasick geredet 2019 ist sie aus
China nach Kasachstan gefl
sie wollte sie konnte nicht mehr
mitmachen die Festnahmen werden alle von
Minderheiten gemacht wer sich weigert
wird bestraft wir mussten das unseren
Verwandten unseren eigenen Kindern
antun auf diese Weise geschieht der
Völkermord mit dem Mund der Chinesen
aber durch unsere
händ
kasachstan hat vor kurzem die Grenzen zu
China geöffnet seitdem würden
Flüchtlinge aus shinjang von
chinesischen Männern bedroht
zusammengeschlagen erzählt quasibeck sie
fürchtet dass es auch für sie kein
Entkommen gibt vor Chinas Hausbesuchen
vor seinen
scherken